le Canada est connu dans le monde entier
pour ses grands espaces et sa nature
sauvage c'est aussi ce qui en fait un
joueur central dans le maintien de la
biodiversité sur la planète et pourtant
notre bilan n'est pas reluisant
ça ne paraît pas mais on est tout près
de Toronto
on est dans la réserve de biosphère de
l'escarpement du Niagara reconnu par
l'UNESCO une des dernières forêts du sud
de l'Ontario on a rendez-vous avec le
chercheur en écologie Daniel Krauss
c'est un point chaud où on retrouve de
nombreuses espèces en voie de
disparition et menacée en cette veille
de la COP15 nous le rencontrons pour
faire le bilan des efforts du Canada
pour préserver sa biodiversité c'est la
décennie la plus importante pour la
conservation de la nature qu'on n'est
jamais connu et c'est en partie grâce au
cadre mondial sur la biodiversité
quelque chose dans ce cadre est
ambitieux
il a fait une revue des pratiques de
conservation dans le monde et réfléchie
sur ce que le Canada doit faire pour
respecter le prochain cadre mondial sur
la biodiversité
en ce moment
le Canada a une responsabilité majeure
sur la biodiversité mondiale il héberge
les plus larges forêt intactes au monde
60% des lacs d'eau douce mondiaux en
octobre le commissaire à l'environnement
du Canada présentait ses conclusions le
Canada
selon son rapport la biodiversité
canadienne est sérieusement danger au
Canada plus de 800 espèces vivantes sont
inscrites sur la liste des espèces
menacées une liste qui s'allonge d’année
en année parmi elles le noyer cendré
qu'on retrouve ici en Ontario 90%
d'entre eux ont succombé à un champignon
invasif
celui-ci est mort à cause de chancres
comment vous le savez
parce que je l'ai vu mourir
les espèces inscrites sur la liste sont
protégés par la loi fédérale sur les
espèces en périls mais ces effets sont
insuffisants pour les espèces qui
avaient été inscrites le ministère
manquait des personnel pour faire
respecter la loi
une espèce doit être évaluée par les
scientifiques elle doit ensuite être
listée puis un plan de rétablissement
doit être préparé puis ces actions
doivent être mises en place parfois cela
peut prendre des années et dans certains
cas cela n'arrive jamais toujours ce
qu'on se rapporte aussi en n'a pas
terminé l'examen de la moitié des 230
espèces aquatiques qui ont été
recommandées depuis 2004 pour être
ajoutés sur la liste des espèces en
péril
souvent quand des espèces sont inscrites
sur la liste leur état de conservation
de s'améliore pas
aussi le commissaire note un biais dans
le choix des espèces ajoutées à la liste
des espèces en péril de plus le
ministère avait évité d'inscrire de
nombreuses espèces à valeur commerciale
comme la morue
selon l'Union internationale pour la
conservation de la nature 113 espèces
sur le territoire canadien sont
gravement en périls sur le bord de
l'extinction seulement la moitié sont
protégés par la loi canadienne
à Sherbrooke en préparation pour la
COP15 Dominique Gravel tente de chiffrer
les efforts du Québec sur les objectifs
du précédent cadre mondial pour la
biodiversité les objectifs d'Haïti mais
le défi est grand
actuel de disponible pour évaluer l'état
de la biodiversité il y a une liste
d'espèces et un bilan sur le nombre
d'espèces qui sont protégées mais ça se
limite à ça son équipe est lui veulent
combler ce manque centraliser les
données pour faire le suivi de
l'évolution de la biodiversité dans la
province d'abord pour évaluer le seul
des objectifs chiffrés de l'accord
d'Haïti protéger 17% des terres avant
2020 il nous présente la carte des airs
protégées du Québec alors on a atteint
le 17% la cible de 17% qui avait dans
les objectifs d'Haïti et on l'a atteint
en allant placer des uns protégés dans
le Nord ou c'était un petit peu plus
facile ou ce sont des terres publics et
où il y a pas beaucoup de développement
actuellement paradoxalement les espèces
menacées sont situées dans le sud du
Québec alors on protège très peu les
endroits où on retrouve ces espèces là
pourtant l'accord d'Haïti requiert que
les territoires protégés soient
représentatifs de l'écologie du pays à
l'échelle du Canada le pays n'a protégé
que 13,5% des terres sur les 17%
premiers aussi concentré plus au nord
mais d'autres objectifs sur la perte
d'espèces ou sur la connectivité des
heures protégées sont plus difficiles à
mesurer nous devons améliorer ça nous
avons besoin d'une sorte de bureau
national de comptabilité pour la nature
au Canada qui nous rapporte ça vous
savez comme nous le faisons sur
l'économie sur l'état de notre monde
naturel le Canada a déjà annoncé son
attention de protéger 30% de ces terres
pour 2030 cette ambitieux pour ça il
faudra créer des airs conserver d'une
taille équivalente à la surface totale
du Québec ah oui non nous savons que le
Canada veut avoir un cadre mondial
ambitieux pour la biodiversité
arrêtez et inverser la perte de la
nature ce serait immense stopper la
perte des terres humides dans le sud de
l'Ontario la perte des prairies voir le
nombre d'oiseaux chanteurs augmentés au
lieu de diminuer
ce serait une immense immense
réalisation
[Musique]